♪♪
(Barking)
Finch is the last man on Earth,
maybe.
Tom Hanks:
There's hints of other people
out there,
Tom Hanks:
but as far as his part of
metropolitan St. Louis,
he's the only guy left.
♪♪
But he has the greatest
companion in the world.
Tom Hanks:
He has a dog, Goodyear.
(Barking)
Hey, I missed you.
Tom Hanks:
Finch is an engineer and he has
built a robot to help take care of Goodyear.
Tom Hanks:
His name is Jeff.
Jeff:
Hello, dog.
Finch:
You have a friend!
When word of this massive storm
comes on,
Tom Hanks:
they gotta pile into the family RV
and take off
♪♪
Tom Hanks:
to the the promise land out
west.
♪♪
(Car horn honking)
Jeff:
San Francisco, here we come.
♪♪
It is not human to be alone,
Tom Hanks:
because in company we find
companionship...
Jeff:
I believe in you, Finch.
...we find love.
Do you understand how important
this dog is to me?
Jeff:
Yes.
The bond between Finch and
Goodyear...
(Puppy whining)
Tom Hanks:
...is one that is based on
deep affection,
♪♪
Tom Hanks:
and constant understanding.
♪♪
(Tap, tap, tap)
Who doesn't love a good dog?
Tom Hanks:
Even Jeff loves a good dog.
(Barking)
What's all the fuss?
Jeff:
I thought our communication
might improve if I learned to talk dog.
(Growling)
♪♪
The beautiful thing about the
film
is that it's optimistic,
♪♪
hopeful,
and it's just delightful.
Jeff:
Come on, boy.
What do you think?
(Dog whimper)
(Barking)
♪♪